foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar current
controversies in the diagnosis and
treatment of trichomonas vaginalis and
mycoplasma genitalium I am Sabrina Lemos
of lab roots and I'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
and brought to you by Abbott to learn
more visit abbott.com this webinar is
educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education window
at the bottom of your screen to obtain
your credits after the webinar we
encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation this webinar will include
multiple interactive polling questions
throughout the presentation we ask that
you please participate in these as they
come up to do so simply use your cursor
to select the answer best fitting and
the speakers will be able to see your
response in real time I'd now like to
welcome our speakers Dr Christina munzey
associate professor of medicine
epidemiology and Obstetrics and
Gynecology at the infectious diseases
division at the University of Alabama at
Birmingham and Dr William Geisler
professor of medicine epidemiology at
the infectious diseases division at the
University of Alabama at Birmingham Dr
munzi you may now begin your
presentation welcome
all right good morning everyone and
thank you all for being here today
so these are my disclosures for this
presentation research grants to my
institution salary consulting fee
speaker and reviewer honoraria and I
just want to remind everyone that this
program is sponsored by Abbott and we
are presenting on behalf of Abbott and
the content of this program is in
compliance with Abbott's applicable
regulatory requirements
so I'm going to start talking about
trichomonas vaginalis and then Dr Geiser
will end by talking about mycoplasma
genitalium so the learning objectives
for my portion are to provide a brief
overview of the epidemiology clinical
manifestations and consequences of
trichomonas in women and men
also to discuss current controversies
and screening and diagnostic testing
recommendations for this STI
then to provide an overview of currently
available diagnostic tests and finally
to review the current controversies of
treatment of trichomonas in women and
men
so just to briefly review epidemiology
of trichomonas in U.S women and men this
STI prevalence has been found to be 1.8
percent among women and 0.5 percent
among men in the national health and
nutrition examination survey this was
first published in 2018 this was the
first time that the inhanes had tested
men in their study and also the first
time that a highly sensitive nucleic
acid amplification test was performed
for both women and men
the participants in this study were ages
18 to 59 years old there was a very
significant racial disparity with
regards to trichomonas infection in the
study in the African-American population
with African-American women having a
prevalence of 8.9 percent in
African-American men having a prevalence
of 4.2 percent
other factors associated with
trichomonas were older age
less than a high school education being
below the poverty level and having
greater than or equal to two sexual
partners in the past year
with regards to epidemiology of
trichomonas here in Alabama where Dr
Geisler and I are we have a very busy
Health Department Public Health clinic
and this Clinic actually initiated
routine screening for Trichomoniasis
among all women and men coming to the
clinic in 2012 so almost over a decade
ago
we looked at the first Year's worth of
data based on nucleic acid amplification
testing on these patients
we found the overall trichomonas
prevalence at our Clinic was 20 percent
so very high actually when you
stratified by gender it was 27 in women
and 9.8 percent in men
the lower prevalence in men although it
is higher than the national average
maybe due to spontaneous resolution of
trichomonas in men which can occur in
some men but the host and parasite
factors associated with this are not
poorly characterized
um importantly in this study trichomonas
not detected a third more infections in
women than if um wet Mount alone was
performed
with regards to clinical consequences of
untreated trichomonas infection in men
it can cause non-gonococcal urethritis
penile discharge dysuria there's also a
known increased risk of HIV infection
infertility in men and then there's
questionable data some for and against
whether or not trichomonas increases the
risk of prostate cancer
in women trichomonas is associated with
multiple adverse outcomes including
vaginitis cervicitis endometritis and an
increased risk of post-gynecologic
surgical infections in addition multiple
studies and meta-analyzes have found
that trichomonas increases the risk of
adverse birth outcomes in women similar
to men there's also an increased risk of
HIV acquisition for women there is a
known association with an increased risk
of HPV human papillomavirus infection
and cervical cancer this has been noted
in a meta-analysis of multiple studies
looking at the risk of trichomonas and
cervical cancer also in women it can
cause infertility and fallopian tube
damage
however despite its high prevalence and
multiple adverse clinical consequences
trichomonas right now in the United
States is not nationally reportable
there are currently no established
screening surveillance or control
programs for women or men
routine screening right now is only
recommended in hiv-infected women at
entry to care and annually
screening can be considered for persons
in high prevalence settings such as STI
clinics and correctional facilities and
also for asymptomatic persons at high
risk those would include people with
multiple sexual partners people engaging
in exchange of sex for money or drugs
people illicitly using drugs or people
with an STI history
why do we not have trichomonas being a
reportable sexually transmitted
infection in this country
um
apparently you have to have meet all
seven criteria to be a nationally
reportable infection
a paper was written about this over a
decade ago now stating that trichomonas
only meets three out of seven of these
National criteria
with regards to a meets frequency being
a common sexually transmitted infection
it meets the criteria of having
Associated disparities and adverse
Health outcomes as I have outlined on a
previous slide and it also
communicability we know that it is a
sexually transmitted infection
however the other four criteria severity
Associated cost preventability and
public interest have not been met by
trichomonas
um however this you know these criteria
the rationale for this was published 10
years ago now and these other four
criteria are very controversial now
which I'm happy to talk about that at
the end of the presentation if there's
any questions about this
so right now not all successful STI
control measures are being used for
Trichomoniasis we have very sensitive
screening tests and diagnostic tests
which I will briefly overview later on
uh particularly the the highly sensitive
nucleic acid amphication test
um we also have availability a very
effective affordable medications which
metronidazole is the most commonly used
medication for trichomoniasis and it is
the most affordable treatment for any
STI in this country
accurate reporting of cases however is
not available nor is mandatory reporting
to the CDC for trichomonas as it is not
a national reportable disease
we also have expedited partner therapy
of treatment of infective sexual
partners this is permissible across the
country except in four states right now
of which Alabama is one of them however
in history though EPT has mainly been
used for treatment of sexual partners
for those with chlamydia and gonorrhea
and data on its use in the real world
for Trichomoniasis is minimal
with regards to clinical manifestations
there are multiple symptoms and signs
that trichomonas can cause however it is
important to note that infection may be
asymptomatic in a proportion of patients
for those who are symptomatic it can
cause women having vaginal discharge
that gets worse during their
menstruation it can cause genital
itching dysuria and disparenturia for
men it can cause a penile discharge and
also dysuria
signs in women can include vaginal
erythema a yellow green frothy mild
odorous vaginal discharge which the
picture on the top shows that vaginal
discharge it can occasionally cause
what's called a strawberry cervix which
are punctate mucosal hemorrhages and the
cervical
epithelial cells
also with regards to the vaginal pH it
can be elevated in trichomoniasis but
importantly it can also be normal
so this brings us to our first case in
my section this is a 30 year old
African-American woman who presents to
the clinic with worsening vaginal
discharge over the past week she reports
a new male sexual partner who she met on
a dating app Bumble a few weeks ago
they have been having unprotected penal
vaginal sex and oral sex she has a
Mirena IUD that has been in place over
the past six months and she has not had
minces during this time
she cannot remember when she last got
screened for HIV or STIs
a pelvic exam is performed on her in
clinic in which she is found to have
cervical discharge that is pooling in
her posterior vaginal fornix there's no
uterine or adenexal tenderness her IUD
string is visible
There is mild bleeding occurring with
cervical specimen collection for STI
testing no other abnormalities are noted
her vaginal pH is found to be mildly
elevated at 4.7
her wet Mount had no clue cells no
trichomonas noted many white blood cells
and several red blood cells her whiff
test was mildly positive her Koh smear
did not show any yeast and her urine
pregnancy test was negative
so for our first poll question today
what additional tests would you order at
this time
so everyone can start putting their
answer in on this and we will view the
results in just a few seconds I will
read through the choices quickly would
you get an endocervical Nat test for
chlamydia gonorrhea and trichomonas
would you get an endocervical knot for
chlamydia gonorrhea trichomonas and
mycoplasma genitalium
would you get an endocritical knot for
chlamydia gonorrhea trichomonas and also
get a blood test for HIV and syphilis or
would you not order any additional tests
for her at this time
so please include your polling results
um I am seeing a few responses right now
I will give you all a few additional
seconds for people to continue entering
their results
all right so it seems like we have a
mixture of responses so I'm glad that no
one is picking would not order any
additional tests because that definitely
is not the right answer
so the correct answer here is what the
majority of people are picking which is
the endocervical gnat for chlamydia
gonorrhea trichomonas and getting a
blood test for HIV and syphilis that is
the correct answer
um the one right above that that
includes mycoplasma genitalium testing
is not correct
um and Dr Geisler and his portion of the
presentation will tell you why this is
not correct and this is currently
controversial
all right moving on to our next poll
question what treatment would you give
this patient now you can start putting
in your responses
would you give her a shot of Ceftriaxone
and doxycycline
and the first answer B would you give
her stuff triaxone plus oxycycline plus
seven days of metronidazole
would you just give her metronidazole
only for seven days or would you not
give her any treatment at this time and
wait for your test results to come back
so I'll give everyone
a few seconds to put their answers in
thank you
all right so a lot of people actually
want to give this lady metronidazole
um
however right now in real time the
correct answer is actually the first one
so
that correct answer is ceftraxone and
doxycycline because this lady does have
cervicitis which you have
determined based on her physical exam I
know we're in a trichomonas lecture
right now so everybody's going to want
to give metronidazole
um however so far we don't have any
evidence that she does have trichomonas
infection
so to follow up on this case she was
empirically treated for cervicitis with
answer a per current 2021 CDC STI
treatment guidelines
given the presence of blood it was
unknown of her borderline elevated
vaginal pH and her whiff tests were
truly positive
um
because no clue cells or trichomonas
were seen on wet Mount thus originally
she was not treated for BV or
trichomonas however her STi test results
came back one week later and were
positive for both chlamydia and
trichomoniasis
the clinic had difficulty contacting her
and she did not return for treatment of
trichomonas until an additional one week
later
so I will say for all of those of you
who picked metronidazole in the prior
question that actually is not a wrong
answer
um Everybody did have high suspicion of
trichomonas in this case however
remember that wet Mount only detects
about two-thirds of the infection the
sensitivity of a wet Mount is between 44
and 68 percent and for this patient it
did not detect the trichomonas that this
woman had that she was infected with
so going into Diagnostics briefly
um the traditional diagnosis for
Trichomoniasis is based on wet Mount and
culture so wet Mount is a point of care
test you can see here on the picture on
the left which was taken by my PhD
student chiante Graves of a modal
trichomona that has a flagella you will
see the flagella moving typically it is
important to note that wet Mount must be
performed within 10 to 20 minutes after
specimen collection or these trichomonas
will lose their viability however this
test is not very sensitive as I have
mentioned although it is a hundred
percent specific
with regards to culture this is done by
using an in pouch
culture media this pouch on the picture
on the right has to be inoculated within
one hour of specimen collection for
women it could be a vaginal secretion
men it could be a urethral swab urine
sediment or semen for men multiple
specimen inoculation of this is
recommended to increase the yield of a
positive culture result
despite all of this the sensitivity of
culture is also not great between 44 to
75 percent
um there is another point of Care Rapid
test that is clear way for
Trichomoniasis that is the awesome
testic this is a rapid antigen test for
trichomonas it is only approved in women
on vaginal secretions it is not
validated in men so this cannot be used
in Men it does use antibodies to detect
trichomonas protein antigens with
results in less than 10 minutes however
sensitivity is better than Wet Mountain
culture at 82 to 95 percent
over the past decade there have been a
large number of trichomonas highly
sensitive nucleic acid amplification
tests that have come down the pipeline I
have them summarized in this slide in
the next two slides after this there are
instrument-based tests and there are
also small device tests I will go
through what distinguishes each of these
tests briefly in this presentation I'm
not going to go into
very specific details the first one that
came out is the hologic Optima test
which came out in 2011. this one is only
FDA cleared in specimens from women
it has to be internally validated in
specimens for men prior to being used
there are no real-time results on this
test
the next one that came out is the BD
probe Tech QX t-vaginalis Nat test
um the first version of this test came
out is also only FDA approved in women
has to be internally validated in men
with no real-time results they had a
Next Generation assay on this come out
in 2016 which is FDA cleared for both
female specimens and male urine but
still no real-time results
has their Gene expert trichomonas mat
test which came out in 2018. this one is
FDA cleared up front in both women and
men and can provide results in 40 to 65
minutes on demand
the Roche kobas trichomonas mycoplasma
genitalium assay came out in 2019 this
one is also FDA cleared in women and men
there are no real-time results this is
the first trichomonas not test that also
includes mycoplasma genitalium
results Dr Geisler is going to talk
about this more during his presentation
but it is a little controversial about
what settings you would order this
particular test in as currently it's not
recommended to screen all people from
mycoplasma genitalium
um finally we have the Abbott alinity
assay which is our newest trichomonas
assay that came out in 2022 this test is
FDA cleared for four pathogen testing
for gonorrhea chlamydia trichomonas and
mycoplasma genitalium
um for female and male specimens and you
can get this test result within less
than 115 minutes
finally for the instrument free
trichomonas not test there is one that
is currently FDA approved and clear wave
that is the visby sexual health testing
device which came out in 2021 you see a
picture of the device on the right this
is a single-use point of care device for
detection of chlamydia gonorrhea and
trichomonas this one is only FDA cleared
for use in women right now on
self-collected vaginal swabs results are
available in less than 20 minutes
finally I'm just going to talk about
treatment and trichomonas I want
everybody to be aware that the updated
CDC guidelines did have a major change
in recommended treatment in women
before it was a two gram stat dose of
oral metronidazole for all HIV negative
women with multi-dose Metronidazole only
being recommended in HIV positive women
that was in the 2015 guidelines in the
2021 guidelines we now have moved to
recommending multi-dose metronidazole
for all women HIV positive and negative
um this is due to randomized control
clinical trial data which I'll briefly
review in the next slide however due to
lack of data in men the oral
metronidazole single dose 2 gram stat
and Men is still the recommended
treatment
so this is the first time we have
discordant first line recommended
treatment that is different based on
gender for an STI
there is still an alternative treatment
regimen for women and men which is oral
to nidazole 2 gram stat dose
so basically the recommended treatment
in women got updated to multi-dose
metronidazole based on the results of a
randomized controlled trial that we did
here in Birmingham also at New Orleans
Louisiana and Jackson Mississippi
we recruited HIV negative women into
this trial over a three-year time period
we assess 1028 women for eligibility in
this trial and ended up enrolling 623
they were randomized one to one for a
two gram dose of oral metronidazole
versus 500 milligrams twice a day for
seven days the primary outcome was
trichomonas infection by intent to treat
a test of cure four weeks after
completion of treatment
and for the primary outcome of the study
women in the multi-dose group were
significantly less likely to be
trichomonas positive at test of cure
compared to women in the single dose
group this was 11 versus 19
and was very statistically significant
so finally my last comment about
trichomonas treatment since the CDC
guidelines came out we do have a Next
Generation oral 5 nitro-midazole which
has become available and this is oral
signitisol 2 gram single dose
um we did do a randomized controlled
trial at two sites across uh 10 sites
I'm sorry across the United States for
this study this was a delayed treatment
placebo-controlled study however
everybody in this trial got treated for
Trichomoniasis within 6 to 12 days
um we did find that oral signatosol
efficacy was 92.2 percent in this study
and it was a hundred percent and HIV
infected women in the study compared to
Placebo of 1.5 percent based on the
results of this study and also studies
done in Men in Europe oral signatosol
was FDA approved in June of 21 for the
treatment of trichomoniasis in women and
men in this country
however a current controversy in the
field is where does oral signatosol fit
into the recommended and alternative
treatment regimens for Trichomoniasis in
women and men
for follow-up after treatment retesting
after treatment for trichomonas is
recommended for all sexually active
women less than three months after their
initial diagnosis
whether or not they believe their sex
partners are treated
and if re-testing at three months or
sooner is not possible clinicians should
retest whenever women next seek their
medical care less than a year after
their trichomonas diagnosis
for my final slide I just want to do the
summary of the trichomonas diagnosis and
treatment controversies currently
occurring right now
the first is that trichomonas is not
nationally reportable although it is
highly prevalent especially in women and
has significant adverse Health outcomes
I think moving forward we need to have
more data on those four criteria that
were controversial in the past
the second is that screening and
asymptomatic women is only recommended
in certain at-risk groups as I have
described yet we have all of these
available Nat tests that are highly
sensitive and specific and they are in
use how is that going to be moving
forward is screening for asymptomatic
women going to be recommended in the
future particularly giving all the
adverse Health consequences associated
with this infection
in addition the recommended treatment
regimen as I have mentioned in women and
men is now discordant based on gender
are we going to continue to do this
moving forward we should do treatment
trials in men how will this influence
partner management going forward this
discordance and finally the oral
signatosol which is now available where
does this fit in to recommended
treatment
so I'm going to end here and move on to
Dr geisler's portion of the presentation
about mycoplasma genitalium so Dr
Geisler it is time for you to start
thank you all
okay thank you Christina that was great
job well done so I'll take over from
here I'm going to talk about Michael
Posner genitalium and here are my
disclosures you see listed here for
research grants Consulting and speaking
honoraria
so the learning objectives for my talk
will be to briefly give you an overview
of the epidemiology in clinical
manifestations of mycoplasma genitalium
I'm mostly going to focus then on
discussing the m genitalium test the
testing recommendations and some of the
controversies in testing and then I'm
going to review antibiotic resistance
concerns within genitalium what the
treatment recommendations are for
engineer time and some of the
controversies in treatment
so Michael passage in Italian infection
in recent years has been called an
emerging STI but I'm here to tell you
that it has emerged and it's very
significant and so Michael Pasadena time
is a highly prevalent STI and I'll show
you some of that data in just a minute
it's one that may cause reproductive
morbidity that's similar to chlamydia
and we'll we'll get into that it's one
that may increase your risk for HIV
transmission and there's a lot of
studies published on that it is one
where antibiotic resistance is a major
concern in trying to treat this
infection and we do have limited
treatment options as a result and then
finally it's one that we don't have a
vaccine to prevent and so that's a major
concern moving forward with such limited
treatment options
for so first how common is Michael Plaza
genitalium well if you look in research
studies in the general population and
general population studies are ones that
tend to have patients who have lower STI
risk and are typically going to be
asymptomatic for most patients there
have been studies published in the U.S
in the state from the state of New
Mexico and Britain and Denmark all
looking at imogenitalium prevalence in a
general population in a males of
prevalence is about one percent
uh in females are prevalence in some of
the older population studies range from
about one to two percent which is a
little bit less than what we see with
chlamydia but in the New Mexico study
the more recent one it ranged from about
four to six percent in younger women and
it raises the point that engine in
Italian prevalence may be even
increasing because of its resistance but
now these were research studies I think
as Christina mentioned and I'm gonna I'm
gonna mention it a couple of times today
there are no current recommendations for
screening asymptomatic people for in
genitalium so we don't really have
observational data from routine care and
asymptomatic people
but I will tell you that imagine Italian
is much more prevalent in U.S Clinic
populations ones where they offer some
sort of sexual health care and so if you
look in this figure the the orange color
or the gold color is is men and you can
see that the Indian Italian prevalence
in men and these published studies
ranges from about six to Seventeen
percent uh in the case of females which
is the silver color bars here engine
Italian prevalence ranges from about
five to twenty four percent so it's very
prevalent in clinic-based populations
and this prevalence mirrors what we
would see with um
uh chlamydia
as far as uh what are the predictors or
risk factors for engineer time infection
they're quite similar to what we see
with chlamydia and that is younger age
multiple sex partners or a new sex
partner are those individuals who report
being of a non-white race or ethnicity
those are the groups that have the
highest rates of infection again similar
to chlamydia
in terms of the clinical manifestations
of ingenitalium infection they are are
also similar to chlamydia in that men
the most common manifestation is going
to be urethritis and of men with
urethritis you will find engine Italian
in about 20 to 35 percent so it's very
common
however it's fairly rare from the data
that we've seen so far that that you get
epididymitis from in genitalium and
Studies have reported that and then with
products you can identify in genitalium
but it's fairly uncommon in women's
service status is probably a pretty
common manifestation of M genitalium
there's certainly good evidence to prove
I think that ingenatalium causes
cervicitis there's moderate evidence
that's associated engineer time with PID
as well though this is very debated I
would say amongst many in this field
there is however pretty limited evidence
about engineer time causing either
infertility or perinatal complications
at this time
there's been a few studies that have
Associated vaginal discharge with
ingenetime as well and I bring this up
because you know often patients who have
genital symptoms now females may not get
speculum evaluations anymore they may
simply just get a vaginal swab collected
for a wet Mount so you might not look at
their cervix to know if they have
cervicitis so if you have a woman with
vaginal discharge and no obvious cause
for it and they're failing other
treatments you might want to think about
engineer time as a cause of the vaginal
discharge that's persisting
okay so I'm going to go back now before
I talk about engine Italian diagnosis
and treatment I'm going to get back to
the case that Christina presented to you
and we're going to take it over and go a
little bit farther with this case so
this was uh if you recall a patient who
had cervical infection of cervicitis she
was empirically treated initially with a
dose of ceftraxone IM and then seven
days of Doxycycline but her trick test
came back positive and so um she came
back seven days later to get
metronidazole
and so picking up now in this case she
did actually complete her seven days of
metronidazole however her vaginal
discharge did not fully resolve even
after the metronidazole so she returned
to the clinic for repeat evaluation
about three days later and uh and that's
about 17 days by the way after finishing
her doxycycline she tells us that she
was fully inherent with all these
different treatments and that she's not
been sexually active since her initial
visit however the repeat pelvic exam at
this visit shows that she has service
status findings again so she has
persistent or recurrent services and and
that's going to um
bring me to our next polling question
for the audience so everybody
uh let me know your thoughts should we
test for Michael Posner time at this
time she's got persistent current
services or not so the answer is either
what you think yes or no go ahead and
start your responses
so for time's sake I'm just going to go
ahead and show that looks like most of
you would test for Michael Plaza
genitalium about 97 that is the correct
answer
and that would be following the CDC
guidelines as I will go into them in
just a minute
one more question for you this is a
little bit tougher would you give her
any treatment right now so if you give
her treatment would you give her
metronidazole for seven days
would you give her azithromycin one gram
single dose directly observed would you
give her moxifloxacin for seven days
would you give her seven more days of
Doxycycline followed by seven days
amoxicin
or not give her any treatment at this
time
all right uh so a little bit few more
responses here going back and forth
looks like most of you
would either give azithromycin one gram
single dose at this time or would not
give any treatment at the time which was
the most common answer but the correct
answer is actually the fourth one yes
you would give doxycycline for seven
days and moxifloxacin for seven days
which would be following the CDC
guidelines and so we will talk about
that
all right so first how do we test for
engine Italian well we don't use culture
it's not very useful for clinical care
it takes weeks to months to grow this
organism so what's recommended is to use
the NAT test because it's much more
sensitive and right now there are three
engine Italian gnats that are
commercially or FDA approved in the U.S
and those three are listed here and
they're different in terms of their
technology and they're also different in
terms of whether they test for other
certain STIs
but for any of these uh engine design
Nets or if you're using one that might
not be FDA approved but it's available
commercially the optimal specimen that
you should be testing for engine at time
is First Catch urine and then and
vaginal swamp in women and in women in
particular I will say that vaginal swab
is more sensitive than urine so urine
might be easier but vagiswab is going to
detect more engine and time infections
if I mean the test is on a vaginal swab
so what are the current CDC guidelines
for you should be testing for engine
Italian well what the CDC recommends is
that you should be performing in
genotine testing and then with
persistent recurrent urethritis or women
with persistent recurrent server status
such as our case here
um or you should think about it in women
who have their first episode of PID
and so if you were following CDC
guidelines in our case you would test
this patient for engine to tell you
CDC does not recommend that you do any
routine engineer time screening in
asymptomatic persons and the reason why
they don't recommend is that we simply
don't have enough data to know whether
um asymptomatic infection causes any
clinical disease or burden in
individuals and there could be potential
harm by telling somebody that they have
an infection even though they don't have
symptoms and then you might not be able
to get rid of that infection and so you
know it's not a great idea to be testing
for something that you're not sure is a
problem but might cause patient more
problems from their worrying and taking
other treatments that may or may not
help them
there are certainly controversies within
genitalium testing recommendations I
will just briefly go through here the
first is so just imagine if you're
following CDC guidelines somebody comes
in with urethritis cervicitis you don't
test them for engineer time at that
visit you just give them seven days of
Doxycycline but then they come back at
some point and maybe a week later two
weeks later three weeks later they come
back in with persistent or recurrent
symptoms and then that's when CDC
recommends that you do that engine
Italian testing you still don't even
know at that point if they have
ingenitalium and so the question is
um you won't know their infection status
what are you going to do are you going
to treat them what treatment are you
going to use and so this is a real big
challenge for us it's really helpful to
know earlier on if they have images time
or not okay
the second controversy is is that there
are a variety of STI Nets that include
in genitalium if you're using an STI Nat
to screen an asymptomatic person and you
choose one that also includes engine
Italian testing then basically you are
going against CC recommendations and you
are screening an asymptomatic person for
mgitalium as I mentioned earlier that
leads to uncertainty about whether we
should treat that patient or not I can
tell you that the patient's certainly
going to probably want treatment but is
that the right thing to do and then what
if you can't get rid of that infection
how how is that going to make the
patient feel and what are the concerns
there
and then we don't have any FDA cleared
engine time Nat test that include
testing for macrolite or Cortland
resistance and so that's a concern right
it leads to uncertainty about which
drugs we should be choosing
with that question I
goes either no treatment or azithromycin
when you should have chosen doxycycline
followed by moxifloxacin but a lot of
you might be nervous about using
moxifloxacin it would be very helpful if
you knew whether they had a macrolyte
resistant strain or not
okay so what are the major
considerations for treating engine and
sodium first of all antimicrobial
resistance is one of the biggest and
second of all because we have limited
treatments what strategy will you choose
we use one drug by itself we use two
drugs together will you use one drug to
lower the bacterial load and then use a
second drug so there are lots of things
to think about and how to best treat m
genitalium
in the U.S there are really only three
drug classes of antibiotics that have
been shown in vitro and in clinical
studies to have some efficacy against
ingenicellium and that's the corner
loans such as moxifloxacin the
macrolides such as azithromycin and then
tetracyclines which of course
doxycycline is what most is of us have
used however I'll hopefully convince you
that Minocycline is a little bit of a
better drug actually against
ingenitalium than doxycycline is but
there's other ones that are not bolded
in blue here are other drug classes that
either you cannot get in the U.S or you
can get them in the U.S but they simply
don't have any published clinical
efficacy data to give us assurance that
they would actually work
so the problem is macrolides what we
used to use for trading engine time for
the last couple of decades but because
of the evolution of macrolide resistance
they're no longer reliable and so we can
measure macular resistance based on
looking at genetic testing for macular
resistance mutations in the 23s rrna and
there's been studies looking at
treatment failure rates and one of the
best ones done showed that if you have
one of these macular resistance markers
mrms that your treatment failure rate is
over 80 percent
and so you should assume that if you
have one of these macular resistance
markers that you're probably going to
fail treatment
unfortunately it's our own antibiotic
practices in the U.S that have driven
this resistance using azithromycin for
so many things other infections treating
patients that don't even have bacterial
infections with this antibiotic and so
we really need better antibiotic
stewardship
but how common are these macular
resistance markers in the U.S well
there's not um there's not any federal
surveillance yet for this but I will get
into that in just a minute but there
have been published studies uh and
they're shown here you see this
geographic map and you see the text next
to the map that across the U.S the
prevalence of these macral lab
resistance markers in engineer time
infections ranges from about 31 to 94
with the lowest rates of mrms in
pregnant women and the highest rates of
of mrms in Midwest sex with men but
overall if you just average this data
out the majority of patients who have m
genitalium in the U.S will have a Mac
lab resistant strain and then most of
those will fail infection treatment with
azithromycin which is why that
azithromycin won Grand choice is not
good if you don't know whether they have
macrolyte resistance
uh and there have been a lot of studies
again looking at cure rates of
Azithromycin one gram for engine Italian
Studies that were conducted prior to
2009 about 85 percent of patients were
cured within genitalium with
azithromycin one gram but since 2009
only about 67 percent of patients have
been cured and in the most recent
randomized controlled trial of
treatments were in genitalium less than
50 percent who got azithromycin one gram
were cured and so it's again not a very
efficacious treatment option
which leaves us really with the best
drugs we have for ingenitalium in this
country are quinolones and so that would
be your moxifloxacin unfortunately there
are also equivalent resistant mutations
but unlike macrolides when you have a
macrolyte resistance mutation and mostly
you're going to fail treatment it
doesn't you know the the treatment
outcomes don't always correlate with
presence of resistance mutations with
cortolones and Indian Italian and so
there's really only one quinolone
resistance mutation with M genotelium
that has been strongly associated with
moxifloxacin treatment failure and
that's what they call the s83i mutation
in the parcy Gene and there's been one
study that's really been one of the
largest studies to look at how common
treatment failure is when you have that
s83i mutation and it was about 59
percent of patients failing treatment
with that mutation in that one study
overall there's only been a few studies
in the U.S looking at how common this
par cs-83a eye mutation is and those
studies show the that it ranges anywhere
from six to thirty percent so certainly
not uncommon and unfortunately when you
have this part of C resistance mutation
and quinolones most of those patients
also have a macrolide resistance
mutation so in other words they have a
multi-drug resistant mutation
um here is the Quantum resistance or
excuse me the coin alone treatment data
uh you know prior to around 2013
typically up to 100 of patients would be
cured with moxifloxacin for engine
Italian anywhere from 7 to 14 days of
moxifloxacin however below that that
dotted line there you can see that since
2013 The Cure rates of moxifloxacin
anywhere from 7 to 10 days are only the
60 to 80 percentile now and that's again
because primarily of quinolone
resistance so this is tough I mean if
you fail macalizing you fail Quinones
what are you going to treat in
genitalium with in this country
well that really just leaves us with the
tetracycline drugs and Other
tetracyclone Drugs doxycycline is the
one we have the most experience with but
we know the dioxycycline does not work
well for ingenitalium across multiple
studies the Cure rates are typically
less than 50 percent
and it's not that we've that we're
finding doxycycline resistant strains
it's just that the drug does not work
very well however our micro plasma lab
in UAB which does testing including
culture for engine and time we have
identified a patient recently that had a
tetracycline resistant in genitalian
strain it had increased mics to
doxycycline as well which does worry me
that in the future we may eventually see
uh you know resistance to tetracycline
drugs with mycoplasogenitalium
but I will say that doxycycline does
have a very important role in treating
in genitalium considering we have
limited treatments and what doxycycline
does do is it lowers the bacterial lobe
and so if you use doxycycline for seven
days as your beginning of your treatment
and lower the bacterial load and then if
you come in with a second drug like a
macrolito quinolone then patients are
more likely to be cured because they're
not developing resistance to that second
drug because you've lowered the
bacterial load
so what is the recommended treatment
then
oh well before I get to that one more
one other thing here I mentioned that
there was not a federal surveillance
program for engineered time and
resistance in this country
however there are several investigators
I'm one of them uh who are participating
in a pilot project looking for
surveillance with ingenitalium it's
being done in eight different cities in
the SCD clinics and in those cities one
of them is Birmingham the lead one
that's running the studies at the
University of Washington in Seattle and
it's Lisa Manhart and each of these
eight clinics is collecting 800
specimens each year from men and women
both symptomatic and asymptomatic and
sending it to Mercy Washington for in
genitalium testing and resistance
testing and we are going to be
publishing this
we're going to be presenting it at an
international STI meeting in Chicago in
July so you'll get a chance to hear more
about the surveillance project but I do
believe we need surveillance and my hope
is that when our pilot project is up
that perhaps CDC or some other entity
will pick up the funding to continue
this project
so now uh what are the treatment
recommendations well this is tough
but where we're at with treatment is
really something called resistance
guided sequential treatment and the
proposal for this treatment is that when
patients first come in with a clinical
syndrome like urethritis or service size
or proctitis that you are concerned
about engine is helium being a cause of
it then you go ahead and do Indian
Italian testing at that very first visit
not waiting like the guidelines say to
that second visit when they come back
The Testament the first visit given the
doxycycline for seven days and then
after they complete the doxycycline look
at the test result for imgentine that
you collected
if it's positive for Amgen Italian then
look at a macro lab resistant test if
you have one and if it's macalid
sensitive strain then after you finish
the seven days of doxy then go ahead and
give extended azithromycin acetamicin
one gram on day one and then 500
milligrams for the next three days and
the reason why we use longer in genotype
is because the bacteria just grows a lot
slower if you use only one gram of
Azithromycin day one patients are just
more likely to develop resistance on
that treatment
but if the patient does not have a
macrolyte resistance marker after you
finish the doxycycline then you would
want to uh I'm sorry if they do have a
macrolyte resistance marker then you
would want to use moxifloxacin for your
next treatment for seven days outside
the U.S some patients may use a drug
called cytofloxacin different quinola
but I just told you that none of the
commercial none of the FDA cleared
assays have macrolyte resistance markers
okay
um so I'm sorry before I get into that
one other thing so how well does this
sequential treatment actually work it's
been looked at in two different studies
in Australia and in these studies they
included both women both women and men
including men aspects with men where
macline resistance markers are very
common in both studies almost 70 percent
what they found is that basically if you
use doxycycline for a week then if you
don't have a macular resistance marker
and you use a macrolide it cures about
95 percent of patients Within genitalium
if you use doxycycline and the patient
has a macrola resistance marker and then
you use a quinolone about 92 percent of
patients are cured and these studies
were not directly comparing sequential
treatment to monotherapy so we don't we
don't have that data but the sequential
guided treatment studies do suggest that
this is a good approach
but as I was just saying in the U.S we
don't have macular resistance markers
so CDC does recommend that sequential uh
approach take into account macular
resistance but if again if you don't
have access like most of us in this
country don't have access to macular
resistance markers what does the CDC
recommend that you do
what they recommend is that assuming a
patient's not pregnant you give them the
doxycycline for seven days and then you
just go straight to moxifloxacin you do
not give them azithromycin because again
the majority will have macrolyte
resistance trained in the U.S and most
of those will fail treatment so after
seven days of doxy go directly to
oxyfloxacin for seven days and that's
why the question that we asked you
earlier that's why this was the right
answer not azithromycin not holding
treatment given doxy for seven days and
then moxifloxacin for seven days
so um I said that there are no FDA
cleared in Italian tests that have
macrolyte resistance markers that's true
but our mycoplasma Lab at UAB actually
does have a validated assay that does
have Micro lab resistance markers it is
commercially available for routine care
so if you want to use the test I know
this is some Shameless promotion but you
can go to our website here or you can
just Google US UAB microplasma lab we
can do that testing at the time if you
want to test for macular resistance
markers
so I'm just going to wrap up here uh my
last couple of slides first is there are
clearly controversies and in genitalian
treatment recommendations I've already
alluded to some of these well let's just
quickly go through them
first of all if patients are initially
treated with Doxycycline for seven days
but you're not doing that incident time
tested the first visit you're doing it
at the second visit
and then that test comes back positive
say a week or more later
is there a certain time point after you
finish that first week of Doxycycline
that you need to repeat the doxycycline
again or can you just skip straight to
giving them oxyfloxacin and there's no
guidance in the CDC guidelines for this
um there's no published studies about
what to do in this scenario but as an
expert in this field my recommendation
is that because the bacteria is so slow
growing that if it's been less than a
week since the patient's finished that
first week so a first week of
Doxycycline you can just go straight to
either the macrolide or the coin loan
depending upon if you have mac lab
resistance testing
but if it's been longer than one week
since they finished that doxycycline and
now you're going to treat them for in
genitalium then I would repeat the one
week of doxy doxycycline to lower that
bacterial load again and then come in
with again either a macro ladder
equivalent depending upon whether you
have mac lab resistance data or not
I already mentioned that there's no
published data comparing sequential
therapy to monotherapy so we're
basically just we've just adopted this
in the CC guidelines because this one
study or two studies excuse me showed
that the outcomes look better with
sequential therapy compared to what we
saw in other studies with monotherapy
but we don't have a direct comparison
and we really need that another
controversy is how do you treat a
pregnant patient with engineer time
infection
uh and and you know the the longest
short of is we don't know the right
answer to that really the only drug we
have in the U.S that's safe to give a
pregnant woman for engine and time that
has any published efficacy is
azithromycin but you know you're not
often going to have macular resistance
results and even if you did even if it
was macrolyte resistant or not you
probably would still use azithromycin
but but how long do you need to treat
them do you need to do a test to cure
what happens if it doesn't go away we
don't know the answers to those
questions right now
another controversy is you know we only
have limited drugs to treat engine
atellium and let's say a patient is
clinically cured where all their
symptoms go away
do we need to do a test of cure or
microbial test secure to make sure the
infection is gone because these drugs
again don't work great and resistance is
an issue but you know we just don't know
the right answer right now we don't
routinely do a test to cure in patients
whose symptoms have results
and then the final controversy I want to
mention is that um if a patient with
infinite time has failed a macrolide
treatment combination and they've failed
equivalent treatment combination what
are you going to do like you know what's
your Savage therapy at this point
and so I do have some suggestions there
it is controversial but I've summarized
them on this one slide here and that is
what we would typically do is we would
give a Minocycline
for 14 days and Minocycline is another
oral tetracycline it's very old
tetracycline and you know we've had
pretty good anecdotal success with this
and there was actually a published study
of about 35 cases of engine Italian
where they gave them menacycle for two
weeks and they cured about 71 percent of
those patients and it's very affordable
and so I think that's a good thing there
are two other drugs um one's a
metacyclin which is a newer tetracycline
and the other is lethamolin which is
from a drug class called plural mutans
and these are two newer drugs that do
not have an FDA approved indication for
treating engine Italian and so it would
be off label if you're using those two
drugs
these drug both these new drugs in vitro
in the laboratory look like they should
have good activity against ingenitalium
but neither of these new drugs have any
published efficacy data in humans for us
to have confidence that they're actually
going to work and these drugs are very
expensive both of them are over two
thousand dollars for seven days of
treatment if you don't get insurance to
cover them and you have to pay out of
pocket and so these are not great
Salvage treatment options but they are
available in the U.S okay
there are a few other drugs outside the
U.S but you just can't get them in this
country
so I knew we were going to be running
short on time so I didn't put a summary
slide here I'm going to just really say
thank you to everyone for attending
today as I know Dr Muzzy thanks you uh
if you have questions for either of us
after the presentation today you can put
them in the chat as you've probably been
doing or you can unmute your unmute your
line to ask us if we have time for that
but you can also email us and our email
addresses are right here again thank you
so much
thank you Dr mosny and Dr Geisler for
your informative presentation so we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
all right so the first one that I see
here what about cervical swabs for mgen
or does vaginal swabs Encompass that
that's a great question so no I mean
vaginal swabs and cervical swabs will be
collecting you know from from different
sites the sensitivity or accuracy the
assay is actually pretty similar between
vaginal swabs and cervical swabs it's
just a little bit higher for vaginal
swaps so if you're already collecting
cervical swabs in your clinical practice
that's okay to use those clinical swaps
for engine Italian testing it's also
it's also okay just to use a vaginal
swab even if you are doing a speculum
exam you can still collect a vaginal
swab the point I really wanted to make
is that urine is inferior to test on for
women for engine it's time compared to a
vaginal swab or a cervical swab
awesome thank you and at your
institution what body sources do you
test for trick
um yes for for us we are doing male
urine uh for men primarily um we do do
Pinot miedo swabs
um if needed also for women we do
vaginal swabs it can be done on
endocervical swabs it can be done on
urine as well for women and also
um thin uh thin prep pap
tap specimens
awesome thank you and the next one I
have what are the factors for an
infection by trichomonas for a woman
without relationships
yeah so that's an interesting question
um the very large majority of the data
suggests that trichomonas is primarily
sexually transmitted
so 99.9 of the time
um there are a few scattered case
reports of trichomonas being transmitted
by other means however these are a
little controversial
um one of them is basically pit latrines
in The Gambia there's a paper published
on that of of adolescent children
frequently using these pit latrines as a
group that were virginal and a few of
them got
trichomonas infection during that and
they hypothesized that it was where they
were going to the bathroom at that has
been debated
um as there's no good data to show that
trichomonas is transmitted by just
sitting on bathroom toilets
there's also one case report of an
iatrogenic transmission of trichomonas
from a traditional healer in South
Africa that was doing pelvic exams on a
patient that's also pretty controversial
um in addition to the sexual
transmission aspect of it Beyond penal
vaginal sex you know there's other
sexual activities that occur and it is
known that trichomonas can survive in
wet moist washcloths for up to 24 hours
so if sexual partners are using warm and
wet
washcloths and sharing them to you know
wipe their genital areas before and
after sex there has been data showing
that trichomonas can be transmitted that
way but that that is a sexually
Associated way of transmitting
trichomonas a great question let me let
me add one just quick thing to that too
correct me if I'm wrong Dr Muzzy my
clinical practice I've also sometimes
seen women who get a urine collected in
routine care and they find trick in the
urine but the women say they may not
have been sexually active for years and
I do think that trichomonas can persist
in some women for years so it doesn't
have to be necessarily recent sexual
activity is that correct
absolutely so as you know as I mentioned
there's no routine screening recommended
for trichomonas outside of HIV positive
women so and trick can be asymptomatic
so women may have it for years and like
like you said they may see it on a UA
incidentally uh or a pap smear
incidentally it should always be treated
if it's seen
great thank you we have time for a few
more questions here
um is there moderate evidence between
mycoplasma and infertility in
asymptomatic or symptomatic people
uh no I mean really the the moderate
evidence is actually in pelvic
inflammatory disease and that's driven
basically by people that were primarily
with symptomatic PID where they've done
testing on them regarding infertility
these are women that are presenting to
fertility providers or to be evaluated
for infertility most of them don't have
active kind of your genital symptoms and
you know if they've had infections
there's often historical it may have
been years ago and so and those
infertility studies are often using like
an old mycoplasma antibody assay to try
to make a correlation with infertility
which is just not accurate and so we
just don't have many studies and they're
not well designed to look at infertility
with ingenitalium
great thank you
um this one I have here given the great
disparity and prevalence between General
and specific populations what
establishing a prevalence of both TV and
and mgen be responsible I'm sorry
reasonable first be reasonable first
step in understanding the best approach
to making a recommendation for testing
in specific patients or populations
I can quickly just answer that and that
I think you know it's always a good idea
to have an understanding of STI
prevalence in your setting if you don't
have data that's helpful to know because
you're monitoring your own efforts to
control STIs locally but I will say so
and you shouldn't be doing asymptomatic
testing for engine to time anyway and
only in certain circumstances for trick
as Dr Muzzy mentioned
um but I do think it's helpful to have
that information to help guide you know
your testing practices
great thank you and
um last one here do we know if trick
self-results
um how do we how do you interpret a low
positive and aat result followed by a
negative without treatment
so so there is some data on spontaneous
resolution of trichomonas in men
um I briefly mentioned
um these are done in studies of less
than you know very small sample size of
men less than 20 men and the few studies
that are available on this
um and we don't know
basically we don't know what the what
host actors can predict spontaneous
resolution or any parasite Associated
factors that can facilitate that
the overwhelming majority of data which
there's not a lot is available in men
I'm not really aware of any good data in
women on that we do know that
trichomonas can also persist for long
periods of time
um and it you know a lot of this
uncertainty is because we don't quite
understand the natural history of
trichomonas in women or men so those
kind of studies are really invaluable
and I will say we did one small study
here at our health department here
um of 40 men looking at the natural
history of trichomonas and we did find
that 30 of them resolved their
trichomonas in between getting tested by
a not the hologic Optima not test and
being called to come back to the clinic
a week later so 30 of those 40 Men
actually were trichomonas negative at
their next visit seven days later so we
do know it is happening in some men even
contemporarily like in the present time
we just don't know exactly why yet which
is an area of future research
awesome thank you guys so much
um so thank you Dr muzy and Dr Geisler
do you have any final comments for our
audience
um no I've actually been looking at some
other questions we didn't get to but
quickly urine urethra swaps or engine at
time doesn't make a difference equal
sensitivity on those uh and there's no
reimbursement for engine resistance at
this point in the U.S there's no assays
that have it so I think the point about
engineer time is um it's evolving field
I think there's controversies based on
what CDC is recommending for diagnosis
and treatment I definitely encourage you
to keep your eyes open for newer studies
coming out in genitalium and I suspect
that they'll probably be updated CDC
guidance before the next guidelines
would come out in about five years
because the Field's moving so quickly
Within genitalium
foreign
go ahead
oh I was just going to say a few last
words for the few last questions in here
um thank you all so much we really
appreciate all of y'all's questions
trichomonas is not part of the normal
vaginal Flora so it is an STD pathogen
so anytime you find it you absolutely
want to treat it I can't emphasize that
enough and also for somebody who made a
comment about a geriatric patient having
trichomonas
um you know this that's a very sensitive
um
vulnerable population obviously you do
want to make sure there's not elder
abuse going on if you are diagnosing
sexually transmitted infections and in
elderly people but again for trichomonas
because there's no screening National
screening recommendations people may
actually have it for many many years and
not be sexually active so that is also a
possibility but you also want to make
sure elder abuse is not going on but
thank you all so much for the
presentation today and I'll pass it back
to you Sabrina
thanks everyone
thank you both for your time today and
your important research we'd also like
to thank lab roots and our sponsor
Abbott for underwriting today's
educational webcast uh before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and they're interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab boots lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's event until next time thank you
guys again goodbye
thank you